I know you don't you don't live far from
here you live by the beach is that right
yeah quick quick commute quick commute
yeah hearing a people watching at home
don't understand but we are in as you
can see Burbank and it takes a good it
takes a long time to get here for yeah I
know I live in Venice Beach so that may
as well be a different time zone yes
yeah it took you probably six days to
get here I mean pretty much yeah and
what's it like there are you enjoying it
there looking down by the beach it's
gonna be fantastic fantastic I
understand there is a downside there
well yeah because well act K yes I so I
thought I had some really vicious
seagulls turns out because I have a
carport outside situation am i somebody
likes to decorate it at first thing in
the morning it turns out it's even worse
it's these two really cute nesting
pigeons that have decided to live in the
little eave above my car really yeah and
they like can we take a look at personal
you posted a picture of your car this is
disgusting yeah that's objectively
disgusting why only that the whole car
is exposed but they only seem to go
after the passenger side that's like a
mystery to me wait they understand it's
not safe for the driver on the passenger
side you would think or they know that I
hate driving so as often as possible I
make my husband Drive so I'm the one
that has to stance to look through that
right so you haven't actually seen Los
Angeles in years where you are he looks
super cute driving a Prius with a pink
little racing stripe on it a nice is
that what it has a little racing stripe
you look in the picture there's like
little pink accents and it goes oh
you're right it does my eye was drawn to
all the funny that so it was mine and it
happens every single morning and I take
it to the car wash and then again but
apparently there's this little couple
like live up there right and then
yesterday when I discovered it was
pigeons not seagulls and I went outside
to scream profanity anthem my husband
who's much nicer than I was like a baby
they look so happy I was like in your
care how cute something is if my infant
son hit on my car
I'd have tossed him we'll come on
you